[Musique]
là où culmine les sommets des montaurus
où se dressent les montagnes du sud de
la Turquie au confins des forêts de pin
se découvrent un peuple de nomades les
Yorks
une famille itinérante qui ce matin
montent sa tente traditionnelle
il faut bien aligner les piquets une
erreur et la tente n'est pas équilibrée
de simples piliers de bois une toile
épaisse en laine de mouton et quelques
tapis
je ne peux pas vivre enfermé dans une
maison ou un appartement je ne me sens
pas libre
sont des turcmens sous l'Empire ottoman
et après la création de la
turquiemoderne depuis plus d'un siècle
il résiste tant qu'ils peuvent à la
sédentarisation
nous les Yorks nous sommes les gardiens
de la montagne
la joie de la montagne nous la
protégeons
des générations nées sous les tentes les
yoruques se sont longtemps déplacés à
dos de chameau et depuis toujours il
travaille le lait de leur troupeau
éminaient très encore ses chèvres à
mains nues
regardez j'appuie avec mon pouce
et je tire ensuite avec tous mes doigts
pour faire venir le lait
il faut faire ça sans lui faire de mal
moi je serais plus vite qu'une machine
[Rires]
les familles horrues sont dispersées
dans les montagnes
chacune emmène paître son troupeau en
altitude
la tribu est attachée à cette vie de
berger
[Musique]
et le grand-père de la famille guide les
moutons en musique
les animaux m'écoutent ils ont aussi
besoin de musique quand je joue il lève
la tête
on leur donne des ordres en sifflant
avec la flûte aussi je peux leur dire où
aller
mais les yaurus et leurs troupeau sont
de moins en moins les bienvenus dans ces
montagnes certains propriétaires privés
ferment leur terrain à leur passage
ils disent que nos animaux font des
dégâts autour des arbres et des
plantations alors ils ne veulent pas de
nous
serait quelques centaines seulement à
vivre encore comme des nomades les
jeunes générations ne veulent plus de
cette vie rude en hiver comme en été
les gestes celui de la fabrication de
ces galettes de blé n'ont pas changé
depuis des décennies
nous avons trois enfants et j'espère
qu'au moins l'un d'entre eux va
continuer la tradition ils aiment les
animaux alors au moins l'un d'eux vivre
à comme nous
tout l'attente éminait coup des motifs
pour ses coiffes des foulards plus
traditionnels que religieux de petites
fleurs inspirées de celles des montagnes
la famille redescendra dans la vallée
avec son troupeau à l'automne